(soft music)
- My name is Dr. Sabrina Smiley.
I'm one of the 2022 program co-chairs,
and we are so excited to
host this evening's event.
The topic tonight is
tobacco regulatory science,
health equity, mental health,
and public engagement.
And it's a live podcast
created by Dr. Nii Addy.
And we have an expert panel,
Dr. Pebbles Fagan, Mitch
Zeller, and Kathleen Crosby.
I'm gonna introduce Dr.
Addy and let him have it.
Dr. Nii Addy is the
Albert E. Kent Professor
of Psychiatry and Associate Professor
of Cellular and Molecular Physiology.
He received his BS in
Biology from Duke University
and his PhD in Neuroscience
from Yale University.
Dr. Addy directs a
federally-funded research program
investigating cholinergic, dopaminergic
and L-type calcium channel mechanisms
mediating substance
use and mood disorders.
Dr. Addy's team also studies the ability
of tobacco product flavor additives
to alter nicotine use
behavior and addiction.
He serves on the journal editorial board
of "Neuropsychopharmacology,
Biological Psychiatry,
"Nicotine and Tobacco Research,
and Neuropharmacology,"
and as a grant reviewer
for the Neurobiology
of Motivated Behavior Study Section
of the National Institutes
of Health's Center
for Scientific Review.
Dr. Addy currently serves
as the inaugural director
of Scientist Diversity and Inclusion
at the Yale School of Medicine,
as the director of the
Faculty Mentoring Program
for the Yale Minority Organization
for Recruitment and
Expansion, also known as MORE,
and as co-chair of the Career
Development Subcommittee
of the Anti-Racism Task Force
in the Yale Department of Psychiatry.
He also contributes to graduate student
and postdoctoral training
and to diversity, equity
and inclusion initiatives
through his efforts on campus
and in scientific societies.
So without further ado,
please welcome Dr. Addy.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much
for that introduction.
It's always humbling to hear.
And every time I hear it,
I always have to emphasize all the teams
that are actually in place
to help us do this work.
So I know that's been a
theme of the conference
for all those of you who
are here in the room.
But I'm really grateful to be
able to have this opportunity
to have our first in-person recording
of the Addy Hour podcast.
There's definitely a
different level of energy
that just comes from being in the room.
I'm sure our listeners who'll
be listening across platforms
will be able to sense that as well.
So in the spirit of where we are in time,
I just want to open up and
kind of set the tone to say,
as others have said,
you know, this is a time
where we're definitely
celebrating a lot of things,
being able to move and engage in ways
that we haven't done for
quite a while as a society,
being able to celebrate a lot
of the work that's being done
around tobacco regulatory science
as we'll talk about today.
But at the same time,
we know there's still a
lot that has to be done.
And that's why I think
it's entirely appropriate
and possible for us to hold
both of those things together
as we continue to move
forward as a society.
And I think what we'll be
talking about today also reflects
what's going on in society at large.
Obviously there's a lot
of challenges going on
in the world today, even as we think
about everything that's happening
in Ukraine and elsewhere.
I also did want to acknowledge
that this is March 16th, 2022
when we're recording.
And so this is the one-year
anniversary of the tragic events
that happened in Atlanta a year ago
when several lives were
tragically lost from our Asian,
Asian-American, Pacific
Islander community.
So I want to make sure that
we least acknowledge that
and continue to give space for that
and not forget about the those things.
Because even though that
was one isolated incident,
there are other things
that continue to happen
to members of that community.
And we wanna make sure that we continue
to elevate those conversations
and to move things forward to action.
And of course, that action
is something I think
that can give us hope
as we continue to try
and move forward as a society,
even with all the other things
that we've been moving forward,
some of those things which
you'll hear about today as well.
So with that framing and
that approach, in a sense,
I'm really grateful and
honored to be able to be here
and to host this conversation
with all of our esteemed guests.
I want to go ahead and
introduce them to you now.
So as was mentioned already,
the topic for today's discussion
will be tobacco regulatory science,
health equity, mental health,
and public engagement.
And so I'm honored to be
able to host individuals
who have been in the forefront
of those types of efforts
over the years, and excited
to also have them interact
with each other
and to see how we can even
elevate that conversation
and continue to move things forward.
So I think what I will do
is actually just introduce
in the order that we have
of everyone sitting here
on the stage.
So the first guest with which
I would like to introduce,
which is someone who's
familiar to those of you
who are here in person is Mitch Zeller,
who is the director of the
Center for Tobacco Products.
And in that role, he leads FDA's efforts
to reduce disease and
death from tobacco use
and bring previously
unavailable information
about its dangers to light.
Mitch has been in this role at
the FDA since March of 2013.
And in that role,
he has been implementing the mission
of the Center for Tobacco Products
to make tobacco-related death and disease
part of America's past
and not America's future,
and by doing so, to
ensure a healthier life
for every American family.
Mitch is someone who has
been at the forefront
and working at FDA-related
issues for more than 30 years.
He actually began his career
as a public interest attorney
in 1982 at the Center for
Science in the Public Interest.
In 1993, he actually joined the FDA
under then-commissioner Dr. David Kessler,
and what was supposed to
be a two-week assignment
actually turned into a much
longer foray with the country,
with the FDA, so to speak,
where he was serving as
an associate commissioner
and director of the FDA's first
Office of Tobacco Programs.
He actually left the FDA in 2000
to continue to work in this space
with the American Legacy Foundation,
also had a stint as senior vice president
of Pinney Associates,
and then again returned to FDA in 2013,
and as many of you know
will be retiring soon.
So this has been in some ways
a celebration of his efforts,
and I'm honored and grateful
to be able to welcome Mitch Zeller.
- Thank you.
- And seated next to Mitch
is Dr. Pebbles Fagan,
who has lots of different titles.
I'm only gonna highlight
a few of them here,
just for the sake of time.
Dr. Fagan is a professor and the director
of the Center for the Study of Tobacco
in the Fay W. Boozman
College of Public Health.
She's also the director of research
in the Office of Health Initiatives
and Disparities Research
in the College of Medicine
at the University of Arkansas.
And she's someone who has
been engaged in this work
for over 25 years conducting research
that seeks to understand
factors associated
with tobacco use and exposure
in racial and ethnic women,
low-socioeconomic status and
youth, young adult populations.
And she also seeks to develop
community interventions
that aim to reduce tobacco and
cancer-related disparities.
Dr. Fagan has a number of
leadership roles and initiatives.
We'll now mention this,
the newly funded Center for Research,
Health and Social Justice
She also is a senior advisor to the CDC
and also has put a lot
of time and investment
to training students and faculty members
to advance their research careers as well.
Again, several different accolades,
one I will mention.
So those of you in the
room have heard this,
those listening, I also want
to make sure that you know
that she just received
the presidential award
from the Society for Research
on Nicotine and Tobacco
for her career contributions
to tobacco and disparities research.
So honored to welcome Dr.
Pebbles Fagan to the Addy Hour.
And last, but definitely not least,
also would like to
introduce Kathleen Crosby,
who is currently the
director of the Office
of Health Communication and Education
at the FDA Center for Tobacco Products.
So in that role,
she leads an office that is responsible
for conducting public education,
stakeholder outreach and
regulatory communication programs
designed to ensure FDA success
in implementing the Tobacco Control Act.
These efforts include developing
breakthrough communication strategies
to reduce youth tobacco use,
helping current tobacco users quit
and building stakeholder
understanding of compliance
and FDA product regulations.
She's been involved in multiple
public education campaigns,
including The Real Cost.
And she also has a longstanding
career with over 20 years
of experience in senior level
marketing and advertising
and working on several large
scale multimedia campaigns,
also served at the Ad
Council for quite a while,
and was a campaign director
for 17 United States government agencies,
someone who's been very
invested in this realm
for quite some time,
and I'm glad to be able
to welcome her here
to the podcast as well.
Well, enough of me speaking.
We obviously have folks
who have lots of accolades
and are experts in their
spheres of influence.
But for those who may
be regular listeners,
you know that I always like
to start out just checking in
and seeing how everyone's
doing at this moment in time.
So I'm gonna go in reverse order now
and actually start with Kathy first,
just to see how you're
doing at this point in time
as we continue to reengage
in society, so to speak.
- Thank you. That's a great question.
I think, I mean, obviously
these last several years
have been really difficult,
difficult as individuals,
as a mom, as a wife,
certainly as a colleague, as a coworker,
but I feel a sense of hope
that we're coming out of it.
And I know that more still has to be done.
And sometimes I,
even though my role is to really
pay attention to the news,
sometimes I can't look at the news
because there seems to
be a big bump coming in,
COVID in Europe.
And so, but you know, my mindset
is that it's gonna be okay
and we're coming out of it.
And I'm excited to collaborate again
in a shared space.
This feels so good.
I've missed that greatly.
I've missed the collegial-ness
and the collaboration and the creativity
that's sparked when people come together.
So I'm especially thankful
that we're here today.
- Yes, definitely agree with you on that
and all the aspects you've highlighted
about the hope that we still have
in the midst of everything.
Thanks so much for sharing honestly.
Dr. Fagan, what about you?
- Yeah, I'm excited about being here
after being at the meeting in New Orleans
and the few of us who were there,
and then coming back here to
Baltimore is just amazing.
You know, these last two
years have been a whirlwind,
I think for many of us.
But I think, you know,
we can talk about all
of the negative things
that COVID has brought into our lives,
but there's some opportunities
that it's brought
for us as well,
opportunities for new discoveries,
opportunities for how
we relate to each other
and how we treat each other
and opportunities for change.
And so those are the things
that I've been focusing on
throughout the pandemic
and looking for new ways to live life,
how we do our research
and how we tackle tobacco
prevention and control.
- Thanks so much for sharing that.
Not to jump too far ahead,
but I love the way you highlight that.
'Cause I get the sense that
all of you have been doing that
in your efforts over the years
and are continuing to do that,
even in this phase that we've been in
over the last couple of
years and moving forward,
just using those opportunities
to really move things
forward as is needed.
Mitch, what about you?
- It has been great to be
with a bunch of human beings
in person.
I said it when I took the
podium yesterday afternoon.
There's gonna be some emerging definition
of what the new normal is
for all of us personally
and professionally.
We don't know what that is yet.
I think we all personally
and professionally need
to expect the unexpected,
whether it's the next surge
coming from the other side
of the pond or other global issues.
And for me, just on the professional side,
it's been an extraordinary test
of the people of the Center
for Tobacco Products at FDA.
And I am grateful for the level of effort
during unprecedented times.
It has come at a price though,
for all of us, not just those
of us in federal service.
I mean, the challenge
of work-life balance,
especially if your family
situation involves childcare
or elder care
or any other health-related issues.
We've paid a price, but
it's been very gratifying
to see the commitment and
the dedication of the people
that I work with as we all kind
of have muddled through this
from our home offices or
wherever we're working from,
at home to get the job done.
And I know that that goes
for everybody involved
in tobacco control.
And that to me is what's so,
was the emotional reaction
I had to be here yesterday.
Because we all have day
jobs in different realms,
different sectors.
We're all working towards the same
overarching public health goal
when it comes to tobacco use
and to be back together
with the wonderful family
of the Society for Research
on Nicotine and Tobacco
meant a lot to me personally
and professionally.
- That's great.
Thanks so much for sharing
that, really well said.
And already, I know we're
only a few minutes in,
but so many themes that are
cutting across all the comments
that you all have made.
One thing that really strikes
me about the work that you do
is it's so focused on
people and on society,
but then again, at some level,
it seems that the level of humanity
has actually been increased
over the last couple of years,
as you're even talking
about being attentive
to the different challenges
that people have been walking through,
Pebbles, as you're talking about looking
for new opportunities,
and Kathy, as you were
talking about, hope.
So I wondered if you all
would just actually comment
on that a little bit in the sense
that how has that humanity been elevated
in ways that it wasn't there before?
'Cause again, it's something
you all were focused on before,
but I get the sense that
there's a different level
at which that has come across recently.
So anyone who wants to jump-
- I'll start.
I think that with the systemic issues
related to social justice and inequities
that have always been there,
but coincidentally emerged
during the last couple of years
at a societal level, I sense all
of these things coming together,
because those kinds of systemic issues
have a direct connection to
reducing the death and disease
from tobacco use.
Because when we look at,
especially when we're talking
about the most harmful products,
name your combustible product,
who is the remaining smoker?
Who have we left behind
at a population level
with all the progress that has been made
in the last half century
in reducing consumption and prevalence?
And there's a direct
connection between all
of the profound issues
relating to inequality
in this country and the
health issue that we work on.
So I've seen more of an intersection
between all of that, unfortunately,
because of tragedies that have taken place
in some of our cities over
the last couple years.
But from that,
just to look at it through
the public health lens,
is an opportunity,
because the issue of health
equity and health disparity,
in our field at least has
never been more top of mind
and more prominent because of
what's going on in society,
at least in my experience
in tobacco control,
than I've seen in the last two years.
And while there's huge,
underlying systemic problems
that go beyond reducing
the death and disease
from tobacco use, I can tell you,
in this administration
in the federal government
the issue of health equity
and health disparity
is an enormous priority.
And from that, comes this
huge public health opportunity
for all of us
when we think about who
the remaining smoker is.
- Yeah.
And when you think about humanity, I mean,
of course COVID has forced
us, and not just COVID,
but all of the social
injustices that have happened
over the last several years
have forced us to think about,
what does it mean to
have a humane society?
And, you know, we have used
the social ecological model
for many, many years to
understand the multiple influences
on human behaviors and human development,
but have done very little
on how we intervene
on those factors beyond
the individual level.
And so it has certainly forced me
to think more about that, I've
always thought about that.
And I can remember when I was
at the National Cancer Institute
and I asked a question,
why don't we do interventions
that intervene on social factors?
I was told NIH doesn't do that.
And, but why don't we,
when the fact is that,
the people who are left behind
in terms of smoking are
people who are poor,
people who may have low literacy,
people who are geographically
isolated in rural communities,
people who may live in
segregated neighborhoods,
who may be racialized.
And so when you think about those things,
where tobacco use is still clustered
and people are left behind,
you have to begin to think
about the social circumstances
and the structural factors
and how do we shift and
change those things?
And we started integrating those things
into a randomized trial that I was doing,
because our smokers in
our study were hungry.
I mean, they were suffering
from food insecurity,
and we had to address that issue.
We could not just sit there
and try to do motivational counseling
and help people to keep their
homes smoke free and quit
when they were suffering
from food insecurity issues.
And so we had to begin to address that,
partnering with the food bank
and getting food out to the communities.
That's what we had to do.
- Yeah, really well said,
and really important.
Before Kathy, before we jump to you,
Dr. Fagan, I also just wanted to,
and you started to elude to this already.
As someone who's been doing
this work for so long,
I mean, as much as
you're willing to share,
how has this increased attention,
how have you responded to that in a sense?
I would imagine in some
ways that can be empowering,
but I also imagine that
that's a mixed reaction,
'cause I know I've had some
of those reactions myself.
But how has that actually,
one, how have you respond to that
and how has that actually
impacted your work as well,
as much as you wanna share?
- Well, thanks for asking that question.
When we had to start
doing food distributions
in the community,
we decided we would write another grant
and test out whether or not
increasing food security
has an impact on smoking cessation.
That grant got funded.
And that's part of our Center
for Research Health and Social Justice.
And so we are asking the question,
if you intervene on social factors
that we know are associated with smoking,
but people who are more food insecure
are more likely to smoke
and less likely to quit,
there are studies out
there that show that.
So if you can intervene on those factors,
does it change circumstances for them?
Can we get people out
of the addiction cycle?
But it's also forced me to work
in the COVID arena as well.
I wasn't running, jumping,
trying to become involved
in reducing disparities
as it is associated with COVID-19,
but the communities in which I was working
were experiencing disparities
in terms of cases,
in terms of deaths and in
terms of low vaccine rates.
I mean, some of our counties
still have vaccine rates
that are in 35%, you know.
And so we have a long way to go compared
to Vermont and New York.
- Really important.
And just, you know, also just
wanted to acknowledge, again,
that flexibility in the
fact that you adjusted
to meet people where they were,
even though it wasn't your
original research question,
also knowing that that
takes more work too.
So I imagine there's a
fine balance there as well,
and something I'm sure will come back to
in the conversation.
But Kathy, I also wanted
to give you a chance
to respond to that.
- Well, starting with
your original question,
you know, I have two, I
guess, personal examples
of how kind of bringing to life
what you were just saying.
But first of all, I need to
say that Mitch is a great boss,
because he, over the
course of the pandemic,
he allowed me to do a lot of time off
from work volunteering.
Obviously I took leave, but volunteering,
because you mentioned food insecurity.
During the pandemic for over a year,
our church was asked to help
to reach into the community
to deal specifically with food insecurity.
And once we started getting
out into the community,
I mean, it was,
you know, it was in the
midst of the shutdowns
and there were no vaccines,
and we really didn't understand
where COVID was gonna go.
But the community need was so great.
And the fear on people's
faces were so great
that once we started doing it,
we had more and more and more requests.
And so basically we would
go out into the community
every day of the week and
deliver big boxes of food.
And I would always go on Friday mornings,
and I would see the same
people over and over again.
And so many of them deal
with so many of the factors
that you were talking about.
But what I would like to say
is that it gave me a belief
that we can band together
in times of intense trial,
and we can help others.
And so I felt encouraged by
that, as sad as it was to see,
and the other example I would give,
it was the federal response
to all the children
that were coming in across the border,
our southern border without families.
And so there was a
massive federal outreach
to go into these cities and
help to bring these children in.
'Cause once they step foot in the U.S.,
Health and Human Services
must take care for them.
And so there was a massive volunteer unit.
Again, Mitch allowed
me to leave my position
for six weeks to go.
And seeing these children coming across,
it was unbelievable.
It was sad, but it was also amazing
to see how the American people,
the host cities kind of stepped up
to bringing these children across.
And in both cases, they
were COVID hot zones, right?
It's like working in the community,
tons of COVID and then
bringing these kids in
and working in the community
to try to help them find families here.
But yet it gave me a lot of hope
that we are a society that
can care about each other.
And so not necessarily
related to tobacco control,
but it's certainly, I mean, you know,
many of these kids came across addicted.
Many of these kids had
never had, you know,
even really doctors' appointments.
And so it was amazing the
care that we gave them,
and it really encouraged me
about the good that we can do.
- Yeah, really well said.
And I love the way
that you all have highlighted
just aspects, again,
of touching on humanity in different ways,
some within the work, but some, again,
having that time to be able to step out
of your official role and to
really be able to meet people
where they are.
And Mitch, it sounds like
you've done that a lot of ways,
even within the CTP organization.
So again, just, you know, themes
that you all have continued
to implement in so many important ways.
I'm also curious how these stories
have impacted your
motivation going forward.
I mean, Mitch, you touched
on that with the new normal
or whatever that might look like.
But how is this actually
impacting how you approach things
on a day-to-day basis now
in your current efforts?
- I think just sort of programmatically,
it sort of comes back
to some of the notions
I already touched on.
Because we're working in an administration
that has in my entire
career in tobacco control,
going back almost 30 years,
I've never seen this kind
of focus on health equity
and health disparities.
I think, and this goes way
beyond product regulation.
This is an unprecedented opportunity
for comprehensive tobacco
control efforts at all levels,
federal, state, and local.
And so it's not directly
related to life in a pandemic.
It is directly related to everything
that we are trying to deal with
and struggling as a society
when it comes to those
who are more well-off
and less well-off and understanding why.
Why are entire groups of people
in this country left behind?
In our day jobs working on tobacco,
we know all of the
statistics, they're profound.
And for me, those population level,
when we say historically
low levels of adult
and youth smoking, that's great,
but who is the remaining smoker?
And however you slice and dice
it, educational attainment,
household income, what's
the smoking status
in the household,
racial and ethnic groups,
sexual orientation,
however you slice it,
there are profound disparities
when it comes to tobacco use.
And so the opportunity here is finally,
at the highest levels
attention is being paid.
And for me, the fundamental
question is being asked, why.
Even though I think everybody
in the room can answer that,
that deceptively simple
question's being asked
in a very, very serious way
on, as far as I'm concerned,
inside the federal government
at the highest levels
for the first time.
And whether it's tobacco
use or food insecurity
or any other social or public
health issue that we face,
I'll share Kathy's optimism
that the sunshine that's
being focused on these issues
is giving us opportunities
that we have not had before.
The problems have always been there.
But this is an unprecedented opportunity
because of the attention
that they're getting.
- [Dr. Addy] Really well said.
Go ahead.
- I think one thing though,
and not to take the sad side of it,
but something that's
become so clear to me,
especially in our work
with youth is, you know,
the emerging issues with mental health
and our area, what we
work most closely with
is obviously trying to prevent use
from using tobacco products.
But we haven't always been successful.
I mean, there's been a lot of, you know,
countervailing reasons why
I think a lot of kids were,
especially started vaping,
and now that they're addicted,
they reach out to us often
and with really incredible stories
about how they never used to be anxious.
They never used to be afraid.
Now they feel depressed all the time.
Now they wanna, they
self-isolate themselves.
And it really appears that
on top of the pandemic,
we are seeing many, many
mental health issues emerge.
And our piece is just one of it.
And, you know, I always quote this,
because it was so telling,
because one teen we were
talking to in the early days
and talking about the addiction,
and, you know, he is like,
"You know, all I did was
just add crap to the crap."
And I think that there is,
especially if you're addicted,
you know, as most of you know,
when you're withdrawing from that nicotine
and you need another hit,
it's very anxiety producing,
but when you add that on top of everything
that was happening with COVID,
the fact that everybody was
self-isolated in their homes,
they couldn't go out,
I think that we have a lot
more mental health issues
that are emerging
that are leading to all
sorts of terrible things.
Other type of coping mechanisms
with different types of drugs,
suicide rates seem incredibly high.
So I think, you know, to me,
it's made me realize that
there's just so much more
that needs to be done.
And for me, mental health
has become a real big,
emerging issue that we're
developing messaging on now.
- Yeah, really important.
And I'm glad to hear that
message is being developed,
but also seems like the
conversation is being elevated
in ways that it wasn't before.
And especially, even as
the data's coming out
with all the stressors that
have been added with COVID.
Dr. Fagan, I also wonder if
you had a response to that,
just based in the communities
that you've worked in,
where obviously stressors
can lead to a lot
of these different components,
both from the mental
health side and youth,
from youth side,
and how you've continued
to trying to approach that,
even though there's a lot of work.
- Yeah.
I think the COVID-19 and other things
that are happening in
the world are forcing us
to think about workforce issues.
And how do we retain viable
workforce in all sectors?
How do we continue to build
the scientific workforce,
the practitioner workforce,
and the advocacy workforce?
Those are real issues.
And also create new work climates
for people to live, breathe, and work in
that are more humane and
still get at productivity.
And so my experience during
COVID-19 is, you know,
I went home, I took my
desktop home and it was great.
And I created more work for myself,
because not just because of COVID-19,
but you didn't have to run to meetings.
I didn't have to travel to work.
I saved on that time.
So I could stop at lunchtime, go walk,
come back and still be productive.
Now transitioning back into the workforce,
and you've created an
extra four hours of work,
but now you still have your four hour,
getting ready for work,
coming home added on.
How do we make those adjustments?
And people like Mitch
are retiring. (laughs)
That's his adjustment.
- That's a stressor.
That's a stressor.
- Look, we said we're gonna try
to make people laugh a little.
There it is.
So there was a joke, (laughs)
but those are real issues.
And it's a real mental
health issue as well
trying to make those adjustments
when there's such a great need.
But at the same time,
we have to have strike a life balance.
'Cause I'm getting away from
saying work-life balance,
it's life balance.
That's what it is.
If you lead with the work
part, we get it wrong, right.
It's life balance.
And how do we make that happen?
We haven't had enough conversations
about our transitioning back
to whatever that normal looks like,
'cause it's not what it was yesterday.
People kept saying, get back to normal.
I don't know what that means right now,
but we need to have strategic discussions
about what that looks like.
And I think we haven't
done enough of that.
We have to reframe what a
research field looks like now.
What does an academic workplace look like?
What does a federal workplace look like
that is healthy, mentally healthy, viable,
and productive and not
contributing to premature deaths?
- It's been really interesting to see,
just inside of our agency,
and I can say this goes beyond our center,
because as a center director,
I hear from leadership throughout FDA,
and FDA is 18,000 people,
that the adaptation to 100%
remote or 100% telework,
once we got through
some technical problems
literally just during the
first week was pretty smooth.
And to Pebbles' point,
people got used to it
and actually became more productive
to the point where that raised issues
of actually work being piled on,
because they didn't
have to do the commuting
and they didn't have all the other things
that come with that.
And so where FDA as an
organization finds itself now is
asking some really profound questions
about its physical
footprint going forward.
Does an agency like FDA
need all of those buildings,
or in whatever the new normal is,
is it gonna be, you know,
so different that rethinking
the need for physical workspace
or how much of it is something
that is starting to be discussed?
And it will be very,
very interesting to see,
and assuming those
conversations are happening
in other small, medium and
large size organizations.
I don't think we can predict
what the future's gonna look like,
other than it's gonna
be very, very different
from what it looked like for us
when it comes to workplace issues
that Pebbles was talking about
when it all settles down.
I think it's gonna be really different.
And I think, I hope a much better balance
between work responsibilities,
making it easier on the
people who are doing the work
while balancing familial
responsibilities as well.
- And I think that's really important
that you both highlighted
that there is a danger
to try to go back to
what was normal before
in the sense that we don't
wanna lose everything
that we've learned over
the last couple years,
things that have been ignored before
that now have more attention.
And so that in itself, I think,
is even attention for some,
because there can be this tendency to try
and want to return to what was normal
with all of the caveats
that come with that as well.
So maybe more so for Kathy and Dr. Fagan,
I'm curious from your standpoints,
just in the work that you do
and in the communication space,
how you think it is important for us
to continue to move things forward.
So this doesn't become
passing, in a sense,
'cause there is, I do often sense
that pull for people to,
there're trying to go back
to what felt familiar,
even though there were a
lot of problematic aspects
with what was familiar.
So how does that come up, I guess,
in a day-to-day basis for each of you?
- Well, I think especially
for the office that I oversee,
I think people have
learned to love the ability
to work exclusively from home.
And so if anything, I think, you know,
what I'm hopeful about is the opportunity
to explore what a hybrid
workspace might look like.
And you know, maybe that means
that for really important
times of collaboration,
people are able to come together.
But you know, I think that we've learned
that people can be, can do
their job and do it really well
and not be in a physical environment
where you're all together.
So for me, I think the
challenge is gonna be finding
that right mix, because
right now everybody has,
I guess what I would call,
somewhat of a taste of freedom.
And we really haven't missed a beat,
as Mitch said multiple times,
in terms of productivity and
being able to do our jobs.
It's like, our bread and butter is talking
to the audiences that we're
trying to develop messaging for.
And in the early days we had
to really like figure out
how we're gonna do that, but
now we've figured it out.
It's like it's all done online.
And we really haven't had an interruption
in our ability to actually
deeply have a good conversation
with a youth or an adult.
And so we don't need to go
back to traveling to 28 cities
for 48 focus groups.
We know we can do it online.
And so I think we've learned to adapt,
and I think we're super productive.
And I think people love the opportunity
to only dress from here up
and not worry about what's down below
and walk into the kitchen and make lunch
or walk and have a nice afternoon walk.
And so I think for me, it's
trying to find the right balance
where there's the opportunity,
'cause I also worry about,
especially those who are younger,
who really would benefit
from the opportunity
to listen in meetings,
see how things happen,
see how like creative brainstormings go.
And I do worry that some
of the younger generation,
if they're not able to be in
person when lightning strikes,
I do think something is lost over Zoom.
And so my worries are,
how do you keep an engaged workforce
such that they still feel
like they have balance in their life,
but that you can continue
to grow and thrive
in somewhat of a shared
space, but not all the time?
- Now I'm going juggling.
- I mean, I would love to see
more strategic discussions
about what the new workplace looks like.
I have talked with my team,
they're all here at the meeting with me,
and for career development
to give them a break as well,
come to Baltimore, you
know, see what we do here.
But we've had discussions about,
how do we move to a
four-day work week now?
That's a tough thing to figure out,
places like Finland and other
countries have it figured out.
And the research is fairly solid
on the fact that, you know,
those countries that have
moved to that particular model,
that the people are as
productive or more productive.
And so we have to think
very carefully about that.
You know, the US is very slow
to adopt some of these models
that work in other places
and these countries,
other countries are
doing just fine. (laughs)
They're doing just fine.
So we have to reevaluate our value system
around life itself.
And I don't think reevaluating,
it means that we're giving up something
in terms of making progress,
because the reevaluation
may help us get closer
to progress faster and expeditiously,
as compared to the way that
we have been doing things.
So when I said, you know,
we have to look at these tragedies
as opportunities sometimes,
because if you, you know,
the tragedy is the tragedy.
And if you let it take you
down with mental health issues,
you'll destroy yourself.
So you have to start looking
at things as opportunities
and what can we do
strategically around the nation
to begin to plan,
and I think the people in this
room are primed to do that,
around changing work climate, you know,
eliminating things such
as microaggression,
eliminating things such as biases,
eliminating things such
as structural racism,
the academic system,
the federal government,
doing things like making sure
that women who are
concentrated in particular jobs
are paid fair wages and making sure
that women who do community-based work,
who are out there busting their butts,
get paid the same wages of the person
who's working in the laboratory.
I mean, we have to think differently
about how we're gonna move forward,
but it takes willingness to
engage in strategic discussions
around that in the same way
that private industry has done,
and say, "Hey, what are
we gonna do differently?"
Let's look at the workplace.
Let's look at the goals that
we're trying to accomplish
in tobacco prevention and control.
How do we get there, and how
do we shape the workplace
to get to that goal
without killing ourselves
and without contributing
to the premature morbidity
and mortality by killing
the workforce off?
So I mean, those are real issues.
- Yeah. I definitely agree.
I mean, there's so many
great things to unpack there.
To Kathy's point from before though.
I mean, just in a humorous way,
the only dressing from the top,
if you all will notice that we decided
and made a pact that we were
gonna do the full dress today.
So no one came pajama bottoms,
even though I'm sure
that was a temptation,
just how things have
been going in the past.
But Dr. Fagan, so many key
things, which you talked about.
One, I mean, not to complicate it,
but yes, to complicate it in a sense too,
as you've mentioned in other settings,
those who are doing health
disparities research,
who are often spread thin in the place.
And so that was and has been the norm.
Now you add on this layer
of also trying to adjust
and make sure that there is balance
in the workday and workforce.
How do you, and you've
started to talk about it,
but how do you put those together?
I mean, I guess the strategic
piece is part of that,
but there may not be an easy answer,
but I just wanted to at
least kind of highlight that.
'Cause I know it's something.
- Oh, my goodness.
Sade and I just had this conversation
about two hours ago.
Sometimes, you know, I think it's helpful
for us to vocalize some honest things,
which is sometimes you
just have to check out
and take a break. (laughs)
And if that means you may not respond
to an email ever, it doesn't mean
that you don't wanna respond to it,
but sometimes you gotta save yourself.
Sometimes it means,
and I'll give this
example, two Fridays ago,
my team had a tough day
and I wanted to take them out
so that we could, you know,
we were supposed to do a luncheon
for celebrating employee day.
And I said, "Oh, this
afternoon, let's go out."
They were like, "Nope, no way.
"We need a break today."
And you have to honor that.
And so sometimes you have to check out,
sometimes you have to schedule breaks,
you have to do it for yourself
and for the people who are
working on your projects.
Sometimes you have to allow that,
sometimes you have to
facilitate that as well.
Sometimes you have to say,
"Today, everybody leave.
"We're done today."
Sometimes they tell
me, "We're done today."
And when they say that,
I'm okay with that.
So you have to, you know,
even as a manager of people,
you have to be attentive to folks' needs.
Sometimes you're trying to save yourself,
but you also have to make sure
that you're helping them as well
in this complicated environment.
But doing health disparities
research, I mean,
those of us who have been
doing it for decades,
I say bear the burden
of doing the research
and people who are new to it
may not hang in there as long,
because you really have to be resilient.
There's a high level, not a low level,
very high level of resiliency
that you have to have
in order to survive it,
because the need is so great.
Just like I mentioned earlier, you know,
I've been working in tobacco disparities.
I also do cancer disparities
with colorectal cancer,
and then COVID got added on.
And so, it's a lot.
- That's a lot.
- But there's a great need out there.
But what brings joy to that is to see
that you are making a difference,
that you're changing someone's life.
And I don't mean looking
at the survey data.
I'm talking about
looking at people's faces
and talking to them on the phone,
and my team coming back to me saying hey,
such-and-such really
appreciated what we did.
That makes the difference,
and that keeps you going every day.
- Yeah, really important and
grounding in a lot of ways
as well, despite all the
effort and resilience
that has to be there to maintain.
So in a lot of ways, I think, again,
just giving honor where honor is due
for someone like you who
has been so deeply engaged
in this work for so long
and knowing it's making that
impact is very encouraging.
So I know it's not easy.
Mitch, to pivot back to
you as well on that note,
as someone who is shifting
into retirement, just again,
curious to hear a little
bit about what motivated you
to get into the work in the first place
and what your, I guess your
greatest point of a achievement
and gratification has been
with this little long
and an impactful career.
- Well, other than knowing
that I wanted to be a lawyer
and did not wanna work for a law firm
and did not wanna work for a corporation,
I just wanted to do public interest law,
my career has been
completely serendipitous.
And it all started with the first job
that I had out of law school
that you mentioned working for the Center
for Science in the Public Interest.
But honestly, if my first
job outta law school
had been working for a
civil rights organization
or an environmental group
or a prisoner rights group,
I think my career path would've
been completely different,
but that first job was
working on food labeling,
food safety and nutrition for six years.
And I did litigation, I did lobbying,
I did a lot of media work,
and a lot of interactions with FDA.
And it's this summer
would've been 40 years
of my working on FDA-related issues,
but it was really happenstance
once I was kind of put on that path
and realized the work
that the Food and Drug
Administration does,
whether I'm there trying to advance policy
or on the outside trying
to influence policy
was something that I
was very interested in.
The tobacco work for me started in 1994,
because the commissioner at
the time David Kessler said,
"We need to investigate
the tobacco industry.
"We need to truly
understand what they know
"about the role of nicotine in the design
"and manufacture of cigarettes
"and smokeless tobacco products."
E-cigarettes didn't exist then.
And smokeless tobacco was the poster child
for harm reduction back in the 1990s.
And it just all happened after that.
And it was Dr. Kessler who
gave me the opportunity
to work on tobacco.
And as you all know, if you're here,
you start working on this,
whatever your day job is,
and there's kind of a
different notion of addiction
to the issues.
I'm retiring, but the last 28 years
of my FDA-related career,
it's been a labor of love
with all of the challenges
and with all the ups and downs,
it's been an absolute labor of love,
and I couldn't have planned it.
Like I said, it really was serendipitous
from that very first job right
after I graduated law school.
- I know a lot of people are thankful
for that serendipity
for the effort that you've
put in over the years.
So I appreciate you sharing that as well.
As we're getting close to our time,
I did wanna pivot to some
of the public engagement
a bit as well.
Obviously, you know, Kathy,
that's your official job,
but in a lot of ways,
a lot of all of you are
involved in public engagement
in some shape or form.
But Kathy, just to pivot to you again,
just to talk a little bit
about that within this realm
of the disparities,
'cause I know that's been a big point
of emphasis and intentional.
So can you talk a little bit
about how that came about
and what you've tried
to do within that space,
even as you're trying
to reach broad audiences
at the same time?
- Sure.
So no matter what the issue is,
and you mentioned my
time at the Ad Council,
we oversaw almost 30
different pieces of business
for federal agencies.
But what was the tie that
bound all of them together
was that, you know, we were
trying to help people understand
whatever the issue was
so that they could potentially
lead healthier, safer,
more empowered lives.
And so, you know, for me,
whatever the issue is,
you have to understand which
audiences would most benefit
from whatever the issue is
or which audiences are most
disproportionately hurt
by whatever the issue is.
And then, my suggestion is that we don't,
you don't treat the audience
as they're homogeneous.
You really have to understand,
like in the case of youth,
who were the youth that
were smoking cigarettes.
And when you really peel
back the layer of the onion
through comprehensive research,
you understand that a picture emerges
of those who are most at risk.
And then you have to understand why,
what made American Indian,
Alaska Native teens so at risk?
What makes African
American youth so at risk
for this product?
And if you treat them as individuals,
not as a mass population
and you peel back the layer
of the onion to understand what
their current knowledge is,
what their attitudes,
what their beliefs are,
what their barriers
are that are, you know,
making them do the behavior
or conversely making
them stop the behavior,
you can begin to develop messaging
that will be relevant and persuasive,
but based on the uniqueness
of that individual.
And so to me, it's
about what the issue is,
who is most hurt by the issue,
what can you learn about them,
how far do you need to nudge
them to really help them?
And that's how we approach all
of our advertising efforts.
- Yeah, that's really encouraging here,
just that attitude of really listening
and meeting people where
they're at in the programs
that you're putting together.
And it seems like it's been very effective
from the statistics I've heard you share
over the years as well.
Dr. Fagan and Mitch, I
wonder if you'd comment
on how you've also, I mean, Dr. Fagan,
I'm also just thinking about
all the different things
that you do and the different
layers of your communication
in different communities
and how you've navigated
that over the years as well.
- Yeah, I wanna talk about
state legislatures, you know,
because when I came out
of the federal government
and started working in academia,
I had to figure out how
to communicate issues
around tobacco to state
legislators in Hawaii
and then do it in Arkansas,
which are two very different states
in how you communicate that information.
You know, while in Hawaii,
the big issue that we were
dealing with at the time
was e-cigarettes took off there
early compared to other states,
because their cigarette
smoking rates were down
because the taxes were so high.
But e-cigarettes shot up.
And so we were, our research
team there started working
on e-cigarettes early on,
and we had some of the
first papers that come out,
looking at the association
between e-cigarettes
and quitting behaviors.
Pallav Pokhrel was the lead author
on that paper back in 2013.
But we had to learn how
to communicate issues
to state legislators,
who were unfamiliar with products
who were unfamiliar with
the issues around flavors,
who weren't necessarily
familiar with issues
related to menthol, you know, as a flavor.
And so I had to become skilled at that.
And then I went to Arkansas
where you have a different group
of state legislators who
are very pro-tobacco.
Hawaii was anti-tobacco,
but there's still a skill
set that you had to develop
to communicate things to them.
And so it's a work in progress,
learning how to influence
policies at the state level,
educating people about the
things that need to be done
to protect youth from e-cigarettes
to help people to get help
with quitting tobacco products,
to make sure that disparate
communities have access
to nicotine replacement therapy,
when they call the quit line
they can access those things.
And so I think we still
have a long ways to go
in terms of sharing stories across states
on how you communicate
things to state legislature
to make sure that we are
improving public health
and not harming public health.
- [Dr. Addy] Really well said.
- I think for me and in
listening to what Kathy
and Pebbles were saying,
the thing that resonated
with me is I think about
the job that I've had
for the last nine years,
but having learned from
each previous position
and the people I've had the
privilege of working for
throughout my career.
It really comes down to,
and it sounds simple,
but it's actually really hard.
Understand your audience.
That's what I was hearing
from Kathy and Pebbles.
And when you think you
understand your audience,
think again, because if you think again,
you may come up with something else
that you hadn't thought of before.
And in my job, whether
it's inside of government
and having to engage with
members of Congress, staff,
whoever the incumbent administration is
at the department level
or at the White House,
or whether it's with
any of the stakeholders
that we have a
responsibility to engage with
or media advocacy,
understand where your
audience is coming from,
what's on their mind,
whether it's something that you see
as things they don't understand
that they need to better understand,
or if they're a decision-maker,
something that you're trying
to persuade them to agree to,
but understanding where
they're coming from
and what might be holding them back.
And we spend a lot of our time trying
to understand our various audiences,
and the more effort we put in to that
in any setting and any encounter,
doesn't dramatically raise
the likelihood of success,
but it makes for a much
more productive interaction.
And even when we deal
with tobacco companies,
there's a need for a dialogue
and there's a need for a
degree of mutual understanding,
even if at the end of
the day, there's way more
that you might disagree
with than agree with,
but just the responsibility
to understand your audience.
- Yeah, and again, that really ties back
into that level of humanity as well
as you all have been
highlighting in your comments,
maybe not necessarily with that word,
but that sense has been
coming out as well.
I think that's really, really important.
Well, as we get ready to close,
I would just also like to
give you all an opportunity
to kind of have a final message
to our in-person listeners
and to those who are listening
on all the audio platforms.
So both in terms of what
gives you encouragement,
which you all have talked
about and hope moving forward
and just any words of guidance
that you'd like to share
just with the general audience as well
around these aspects that
we've highlighted today.
So we'll end on a, it's a light
question, not necessarily.
But Kathy, you look like you're ready.
- So I think one thing I
would love to share is that,
nicotine is obviously an
incredibly addictive drug,
but what I have seen is tremendous success
in both preventing youth
from using the product
by finding ways in that
are meaningful to them,
to help them to make a different decision
before they ever try a tobacco product.
And despite the fact
that how addictive it is,
I'm very encouraged that we know that kids
once they are addicted are
very, very open to getting help.
And, you know, at the federal level,
the most I can do with the advertising
that we develop is help them
to convince them to take
a opportunity to quit.
But there are so many
amazing services that
if I can open the door to that
and then hand them over
to, for instance, NCI,
which really helps in a collaborative way
to give them the tools and the techniques
that they need to quit.
So I guess my overall point is
is that if you are in a
communications and messaging field,
if you find the right
insight to the right audience
and you have the right creative wrapper,
you really can break through
and help them live healthier lives.
- Really well said. Thanks so much.
Dr. Fagan.
- Yeah, there are two things
I wanna leave the audience with, which is,
I'm very excited about our
developing new, bold leadership
in the field and not just in
tobacco prevention and control,
but public health and all of the sciences,
because if we're looking at it
from a multi-transdisciplinary approach,
we need each other in order
to really reduce the toll
of tobacco use in this country.
And so, you know, I'm asking
that the next generation
of people get engaged in
leadership opportunities to grow,
to develop and take bold steps, take risk,
you have nothing to lose.
I can assure you of that.
And when you think you
have something to lose,
talk to a senior person about if that loss
that you think you have to lose
by taking various risk is a real loss,
or is there something to be gained
by that risk that you may take?
I've taken risk all of my life,
and it hasn't necessarily
been pretty all of the time,
but I'm still here on the stage
with these wonderful people,
my colleagues here, and life goes on,
even when you take those risks.
When you don't take the risk,
you risk the chance of
nothing happening around you.
That's a big risk,
that nothing changes around you
when you don't take the risk.
And the second point I wanna make is that
when it comes to reducing
these disparities
in populations who have
historically been marginalized
for decades and who have suffered
from poverty combined with segregation,
combined with being depoliticized
and all those things
that cause oppression,
we don't need those communities
on substances at all.
And so, because they're already poor,
they're already in circumstances
that continue to facilitate
the addiction cycle.
And so those of us who have been working
in disparities research for a long time
don't want our communities
on any substances.
You know, we want the alcohol stores gone.
We want the tobacco shops gone,
and we need to leave
our communities healthy,
because they have so many
things stacked against them.
And that's just, you know,
I know people have
different opinions about it,
but those of us who worked in
health disparities research,
that is kind of the perspective
that we have on that
as it comes to addictive products.
- Thanks for sharing so
honestly and so boldly,
and also I appreciate
your encouraging words
to the upcoming and
rising generation as well.
Really, really well said.
Mitch.
- I think I'll pick up
on Pebbles' first point
about be bold and take risks.
I completely agree with that.
But there's a lesson that
needs to be top of mind
when you do that, which is
the bolder you're going to be
in the field that we're in,
given who and what we are up against,
the harder it is to bring
about profound change.
So yes, be bold and take
the risks but have patience,
because the more impactful
a potential policy
or a program is many
times the harder it is
to see it put into place.
So don't give up and have patience.
In 1994 when I started working on tobacco,
FDA went to the World
Conference on Tobacco or Health
for the very first time.
And I was one of the two
FDA-ers that got on a plane,
flew to Paris, where there
was a smoking section
on the plane, and we were
sitting in the last row
of the non-smoking section.
So a lot of good that did
on an overnight flight
with the smoking section right behind us.
And here we were,
we were gonna tear down
walls with product regulation
in 1994, we're going to
the world conference.
And someone said, "You need
to go hear Nigel Gray."
Nigel Gray has been, Nigel
is no longer with us,
but who, a global leader in the field
and very prominent member
of SRT for many, many years.
They said, "You need to
go hear Nigel Gray talk."
And I went to Nigel's talk
in 1994, guns a-blazing,
and Nigel said what we do is so hard
that he was trying to teach
lessons to those of us
new to tobacco control at that time.
And his message was the yard stick
by which we need to
measure success or failure
because of what we do is
so hard is by the decade,
10-year increments,
before you know whether
you have succeeded or
failed on the big stuff,
not on the small stuff.
And I was sitting there having none of it,
because we were gonna tear
down walls really quickly
and bring about this profound
change, but he was right.
He was right.
And so that's how I
would sync up everything
that I've had the privilege of working on
in my career with what Pebbles was saying
about being bold and taking risks.
That's how we get change made,
but make sure you have the patience
and the intestinal
fortitude and the dedication
and the spirit that I know
everybody in this room
and everybody listening
to this podcast does,
because the more impactful the change,
the harder is to see that change happen.
- Thanks for sharing that story as well
and that perspective.
But one thing I just wanted to also add
to every thing you all have
said is just the importance
of community as well.
Because one thing that
jumps out to me is the work
that you all do at a community,
even as you are invested in
these other communities as well.
So I mean, that story touches on that,
Dr. Fagan, what you've
mentioned also touches on that.
And also Kathy, what
you've mentioned as well.
And again, I know I'm pulling
in my mental health component,
but that's so important for us to be able
to be engaged in community,
especially in this work
where we're wanting
to see these changes so that we're able
to support one another
and not get to a point
where we're running 1000 miles an hour
and no longer able to continue the work.
So I just wanted to mention that as well.
Again, just an honor,
to be able to have all of you here
for this in-person recording.
For those who are listening,
I'd also encourage you to
look up these individuals
just to learn about the
impact and the efforts
that they've made and
will continue to make.
Mitch, and I have a feeling
that your legacy will continue,
even when you're no longer
officially in the role.
And maybe there'll be some way
you'll also continue to be contributing,
as I know many who step into retirement
often find themselves doing.
I'll split it that way.
And thanks to everyone
who's been here in-person
for this live recording.
It's been an honor hosting it
and hope that you all really
enjoyed the conversation,
the way we're able to peel
back some of the layers,
so to speak, as well.
Thanks again to all of you for joining.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Awesome.
(soft music)